get 25% off a subscription to Babel by
clicking the link below
Babel helps make our show possible and
it's an app I actually use myself to
improve my Italian and it's definitely
the first language learning app I'd
recommend to anyone go check it out
Elizabeth Warren is now the leader of
the 2020 Democratic presidential primary
in an average of recent polls this is
not my opinion this is math bernie is
more progressive Bernie more decidedly
wants money out of politics
Bernie more decidedly wants Medicare for
all but this is a program that deals
with what is so we are going to discuss
what is and now what people who email me
want it to be will become very very
clear over the next 24 hours that I can
assure you so listen know the polls
aren't all biased and done with only
landlines speaking to people over 80
years of age okay I still have people
emailing me stuff like that No tulsi
gabbard Orica barred however she says
her name at this point I know people
keep telling me it's different things
she is not about to take the lead in the
primary as some people are still
emailing me and saying this is down to
Biden Bernie and Warren and yes
Elizabeth Warren's rise has been slow
and steady quicker lately and she is now
the front-runner admittedly still within
the margin of error let's look at the
numbers first which in many ways
actually resemble Barack Obama's
trajectory back in 2008 we'll look at
that in a second you will notice that
from about April through early September
Elizabeth Warren was slowly but surely
climbing then we had an inflection point
right around the middle of September and
the last three weeks have been explosive
growth for Elizabeth Warren I will talk
about why don't worry if we go back and
look at the 2008 Democratic primary and
Barack Obama's eventual win you also see
an inflection point where Barack Obama's
gains became sort of more acute and
accelerated but that inflection point
happened later in the primary it wasn't
until January of 2008 where we saw that
inflection
now of course every race is different
anything could still happen but these
are the numbers today now let's look at
the recent polls that make this up if we
look at what are now the last 10 polls
Elizabeth Warren leads in six of them if
we look at the last five Elizabeth
Warren leads in four of them so what do
we think is going on here I think
there's a few things to touch on number
one there is disaffection with Joe Biden
that is helping Elizabeth Warren a
plurality of Biden supporters say that
Elizabeth Warren is their top second
choice so when Joe Biden has bad
performances and they've been bad lately
when Joe Biden's campaign is just low
energy it's not good that helps Warren
more than any other candidate because
Warren is the top second choice
according to the latest morning consult
poll for Joe Biden voters that's number
one number two and this is sad I mean I
wish it weren't this way but again I'm
trying to deal on the program with what
things are rather than what one might
want them to be
Bernie's heart problem at least
correlates with Elizabeth Warren's gain
you might remember that last week Bernie
Sanders had his heart incident the same
day actually that I developed acute
appendicitis and ended up in surgery
October 2nd and from October 2nd through
today it has been a decline for Bernie
Sanders you hate to see it but I'm
telling you what the numbers say and
that is a decline for Bernie that
correlates with the heart of condition
the heart situation
circumstantially at least it does seem
to have affected at least some voters
number three and I think this is what
maybe many of you are waiting for me to
say it cannot be denied that to some
degree corporate media would much prefer
if it's going to be one of the
progressives corporate media would
prefer that it be Warren over Bernie and
we know why I mean after I've not hidden
this from you what Elizabeth Warren is a
much safer version of modern
progressivism to the system then would
be Bernie Sanders
so as Joe Biden has faltered not only
are Biden's supporters already
predisposed to go to Warren as their
primary most preferred second choice you
have also seen that as no one else
stands a chance no one's even polling 6%
right now that has been a move on
corporate media to talk more about
Elizabeth Warren than Bernie Sanders I
was looking at some of the coverage
numbers recently a lot of the night time
cable news er or rather network news
channels the half-hour news they are
covering Elizabeth Warren significantly
more than Bernie Sanders and I think it
would be naive to think that that does
not have an effect as well so this is
where we are today now I know that there
are lots of people in my audience who
don't like it and I get it right Bernie
is stronger on health care there's no
question Bernie is stronger on money in
politics those are two really big issues
the one upside here is if you are a
bernie or buster
and ultimately you have to settle in
some way even if you don't vote for her
but if you have to settle for Elizabeth
Warren it's not the end of the world
okay like I I know that there's a lot of
clicks and money in online media for
being unflinchingly pro or anti this or
that but that often makes bad policy and
it blinds people and I don't want to
play that game Elizabeth Warren has many
faults it is not the end of the world if
it ends up with someone who can defeat
Donald Trump for it to be Elizabeth
Warren rather than Joe Biden right
although there are no quit there's no
question that on many issues Bernie
Sanders is a stronger progressive that
being said number one it's not over this
is just where we are right now Bernie
could well have a resurgence and next
I'm going to talk about what it might
take for that to happen but the other
question at a certain point is going to
be one of electability and there are a
range of opinions about whether Warren
or Bernie would be better positioned to
defeat Donald Trump there is one really
strong case that suggests Bernie would
be better positioned to defeat Donald
Trump because Warren will ultimately be
framed very similarly
to hillary even if Warren is obviously
more progressive than Hillary she will
end up with a very similar public
persona and we will have a repeat of
2016 that is an argument for Bernie
being more electable an argument for
Warren being more being more electical
electable is that while some of her
policies are not as decidedly
progressive as Bernie's as unflinchingly
progressive as Bernie's she will be seen
as more of a pragmatist who may actually
be able to make her positions a
political reality and that that may be
appealing to some voters I'm merely
telling you that there are stories to be
told on both sides about electability
which we will ultimately get into for
sure many will be paying attention to
next week's debates to see how is Bernie
looking what is the dynamic between
Bernie and Biden and Warren and that's
actually the next thing I want to talk
about and I think that this is going to
be a very important conversation